[Musique]
au salon du livre au détour d'un kiosque
on peut échanger avec des monuments de
la littérature tissink michel tremblay
c'est grâce à nos codes de français oui
on a adoré c'est vraiment un exemple à
suivre on aime beaucoup et le type ligue
b sa propre façon il montre ce que la
culture québécoise est vraiment à
travers son peuple une joie réciproque
pour ses jeunes admirateurs et ce grand
auteur on a l'impression des fois que
son lecteur vieilli avec choix puis de
tout à condition que des lieux des
professeurs qui enseignent encore ce
qu'on fait puis on est
étonné et d'oublier est bouche bée de
votre spa
cet ami le salon du livre se déroule au
palais des congrès et abrite pas moins
de 500 kiosque de 250 maisons d'édition
et 1500 auteurs participeront aux 2500
séance de dédicaces certains pour la
première fois et c'est un peu jeune pour
ma part à moi parce que j'ai pas cette
habitude c'est à la fois gênant parce
que c'est moi qui métal parce que ça me
représente et en même temps ça me permet
d'entrer en contact avec les gens alors
que d'autres sont des habitués comme
tristan demers qui a participé durant sa
carrière à plus de 360 salon dans 11
pays le salon du livre c'est une vitrine
l'objectif est de huy vendre des livres
il est signé mais donner le goût de la
lecture avant tout pour moi c'est ça la
vraie mission d'un salon du livre une
étincelle qui peut s'embraser et se
transformer en vocations j'apporte les
salons du livre depuis que tout petits
pour les dédicaces alors le c'est à mon
tour de faire des dédicaces aux gens aux
jeunes en plus du salon palais des
congrès des activités sont offertes
toute la fin de semaine en ligne et dans
la ville mais ce 44e salon du livre de
montréal se déroule sous le thème se
retrouver enfin ça fait 18 mois qu'on
est en pandémie ça fait 18 mois qu'on
vit dans notre univers individuellement
sans rencontrer personne c'est une
victoire de pouvoir être ensemble une
occasion d'échanger et de célébrer les
mots ici navy alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal